-Donald Trump made it clear
this weekend
that he is leading
a pro-coup movement
intent on dismantling
American democracy.
First he promised to pardon
the January 6th defendants
if he wins in 2024
and then admitted in a statement
that he wanted Mike Pence
to overturn the 2020 election.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
For a year now,
Trump and his cronies
have insisted, ludicrously,
that January 6th
was not an insurrection
and that all they were
trying to do is follow the law.
At one point, Trump even
referenced a debunked theory
that Thomas Jefferson
had supposedly used his power
to make himself president.
-Mike, had he had the courage
to do what Thomas Jefferson did
but a minor version?
You know, Thomas Jefferson,
he kept Georgia.
You know that?
He didn't send it back.
There was a dispute.
"Hear ye, hear ye,
the great state of Georgia
is unable to properly
calculate its votes."
Thomas Jefferson was sitting
where Mike was.
Right where Mike --
You know what he said?
"Hear ye, hear ye,
we will keep the votes
of the great state of Georgia."
He didn't send it back
to the legis-- No.
All I wanted and a lot of people
wanted Mike to do
is send them back.
-He's never read a single
book in his life,
so all he knows about
the founding fathers
is they said,
"Hear ye, hear ye."
He probably thinks
those powdered wigs
were their real hair.
"I asked my barber to give me
the George Washington.
When I looked in the mirror,
I said, 'Mario,
you've done it again.'
[ Laughter ]
Hear ye, hear ye to you, Mario."
Also, you never want to hear
the words "hear ye, hear ye"
with that accent.
He sounds like a used-car
salesman doing a commercial
for a Presidents' Day sale.
"Hear ye, hear ye.
Come on down
to Bobby Badabing's!
Buick of Bay Ridge.
Our prices are so low,
every time we sell one,
it's a Thomas Paine in my ass.
Oh!"
But one thing you can
always count on with Trump
is that eventually
he'll tire himself out
and just confess.
He can't help it.
He just blurts it out.
He did it with collusion.
He did it with Ukraine.
And that's exactly
what he did over the weekend
in a statement where he admitted
he wanted his vice president,
Mike Pence,
to overturn the election.
-Former President Donald Trump
all but admitting
he tried to overturn
the 2020 election,
which he so decisively lost.
Here is a statement
that he just put out.
"If the Vice President,
Mike Pence,
had absolutely no right
to change
the presidential election
results in the Senate,
despite fraud and many
other irregularities,
how come the Democrats
and RINO Republicans,
like wacky Susan Collins,
are desperately
trying to pass legislation
that will not allow
the vice president
to change the results
of the election?
Actually, what they are saying
is that Mike Pence
did have the right
to change the election,
and now they want to take
that right away."
And this is key.
He added here in the statement,
"Unfortunately,
he didn't exercise that power.
He could have overturned
the election."
-There's no crime
Trump could commit
that he wouldn't
later confess to.
He just exhausts all the excuses
until he decides,
"Screw it, I'm guilty, baby."
If it had been him
instead of OJ,
the quote would have been,
"The gloves don't fit,
but you don't need gloves
to stab a guy."
[ Laughter ]
But this is how it always
is with him.
He stuns you by confessing
and then hopes we'll just shrug
and let it go.
It's like if in one
of those crime dramas
starring Hugh Grant
the cops went to his house
in the first episode all amped
up and ready to grill him
and he just said, "Oh, yes,
I did murder my mistress.
Frightfully --
Frightfully sorry.
It won't happen again."
Then they'd have to say, "Well,
then I guess you're free to go."
So Trump is now admitting
he wanted
to overturn the election,
which, of course, resulted
in a violent insurrection
that has so far produced
more than 700 arrests.
And earlier this month,
the most serious charges yet
were filed in that investigation
when members
of a right-wing militia
were charged
with seditious conspiracy.
-11 members of the
far-right anti-government
extremist group the Oath Keepers
have been charged
with seditious conspiracy.
-The leader of the far-right
extremist group the Oath Keepers
is due to appear
in federal court.
Stewart Rhodes
is one of 11 defendants
who the Justice Department
charged with sedition
on Thursday
for their involvement
in the January 6th insurrection.
-Sedition is a very
serious charge,
especially for a group
with a name
is dopey as the Oath Keepers.
That sounds like a company
that sells purity rings
to high schoolers in Utah.
But one meeting someone sent a
message to the others that said,
"Someone can tell me
if I'm crazy, but..."
You are.
Oh, wait. Sorry.
There was more to that.
Let's go back.
Ugh. I mean, I think we've
all been there, right?
You know, you're about to lay
violent siege to the Capitol
and worry that having
two backpacks
will make you look stupid.
The police I can handle.
The fashion police,
on the other hand...
Listening to these
seditionist morons
talk about accessories is like
listening to the Joker say,
"Is the purple suit too much?
I mean, aren't I already
saying the same thing
with the green hair
and the clown makeup?
I'm just so over this."
Also, what do you mean
a backpack for regular use?
Are you also going
to night school?
"Yeah, I'm just doing
malicious stuff for now,
but eventually I want
to do air conditioner repair."
Or is regular stuff snacks
and waters?
And if so, just a tip.
If you have one backpack
for ammo and another for snacks,
make sure they look
totally different.
"Hey, man, can you toss me
a KIND bar?"
"Sure thing."
"No, grenade!"
"Why'd I pull the pin
on a KIND bar?"
These dangerous idiots
genuinely seem
to think of themselves
as revolutionaries.
At one point,
according to the indictment,
someone pitched a plan to use
a boat to cross the Potomac,
although clearly they hadn't
really thought it through.
I can. Oh, sorry.
Again, there was more.
Let's go back.
First of all, how many people in
an Oath Keepers conference call
have a boat on their trailer?
I would assume all of them.
I mean, that's like me walking
into my writers' room
and asking, "Hey, does anyone
here have coffee breath
and crippling anxiety?"
[ Laughter ]
The issue isn't
no one having a boat.
It's far more likely
no one having a boat
that's good
at sneaking up on people.
They probably all have
those big-ass fan boats
you drive illegally
in the Florida Everglades
looking for snakes you can
trade online for Bitcoin.
I'd love to see one of those
do a Potomac crossing
in the dead of night.
"Remember, the element
of surprise is essential.
Keep your voices to a whisper,
and success shall be ours.
Now let's push off."
[ Engine rumbling ]
"Oh [bleep]
Turn it down."
Also, I love how
that sentence starts.
"Can't believe
I just thought of this."
They're planning a violent coup
to overthrow American democracy,
and they sound like they're
booking a layover in Dallas.
"Honey, I can't believe
I just thought of this.
Why don't we stay with
my Aunt Ida for a few nights?
What do you mean she's crazy?
Because she has two backpacks?
But what is for regular stuff
and one is for coup stuff.
Oh, so now coups are crazy."
Anyway, these guys
were all charged with sedition,
the most serious charges yet in
the investigation of the coup.
And apparently,
if Donald Trump gets his way,
he'll pardon those people,
a new promise he announced
at another one of his unhinged
rallies over the weekend.
-If I run and if I win,
we will treat those people
from January 6th fairly.
We will treat them fairly.
And if it requires pardons,
we will give them pardons,
because they are being treated
so unfairly.
-Man, it is pretty sickening
to see a crowd full of people
cheer for the January 6th
insurrectionists.
Like, at some point,
you just have to admit
this is a pro-insurrection
movement.
If you're at a party and someone
starts doing cocaine
and someone else says, "Hey,
can I get some of that cocaine,"
and then someone else says, "I
went to the bank on the way here
to get new $100 bills
for us to snort that cocaine,"
you might turn
to your spouse and say,
"I think we're at
a cocaine party."
"Oh, maybe it's not
just a cocaine party.
Maybe there's some other stuff.
Hey, Marty,
is there a cheese board?"
"Oh, bro. I can't even think
about food right now."
Yeah, it's a cocaine party.
Also, you guys need
to make up your minds.
Was January 6th a false flag
staged by the FBI?
Was it infiltrated by antifa,
or were they pro-Trump patriots
who deserve pardons?
Because for a year now,
pro-Trump liars in the GOP
and on Fox News
have been claiming
that either antifa
or the FBI or both
were actually responsible for
the violence on January 6th.
-Some of the people who breached
the Capitol today
were not Trump supporters.
They were masquerading
as Trump supporters
and, in fact, were members
of the violent
terrorist group antifa.
-There are some reports
that antifa sympathizers
may have been sprinkled
throughout the crowd.
-We don't know who all were
the instigators in this
of these horrible things
that happened today.
I think a lot of it
is the antifa folks.
-There could have been
FBI assets, federal assets
that really animated
the violence.
-It's been clear for a while now
that the Department of Justice
probably had some role
in the events of January 6th.
It's obvious.
-The rumor is that even possibly
antifa insurrectionists
possibly could have infiltrated
some of these movements
and maybe instigated
some of this.
-Oh, is the network
called Fox Rumors now?
Tucker's set should be
a row of high school lockers.
"The rumor is Becky's cousin's
friend's sister's boyfriend's
uncle's nanny's roommate's
husband's chiropractor
is a member of antifa.
And if that's true,
isn't it possible
that the dog
did eat my homework?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, you may have noticed
Sarah Palin in that montage.
Man, it's nice to see her back
when she was just
spreading misinformation
instead of potentially
spreading COVID
in New York City restaurants.
Can you imagine you were
as careful as you could be,
got your shots and your booster,
and you finally decided
to venture out
and overpay for dinner in
a wooden shack in the bus lane
and you get COVID
from Sarah Palin?
[ Laughing ] Oh, man.
Only in New York.
Anyway, the point is,
these people can't even
get their story straight.
And Trump has even been
singling out some of the kooks
and weirdos who advocated
for the coup at his rallies.
For example, you might remember
that MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
met with Trump
at the White House,
holding notes
that said something
about declaring martial law.
And at his rally
over the weekend,
Trump singled out
Lindell for praise.
-He's no longer the pillow man.
He sells everything.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mike Lindell.
I think he's the single greatest
purchaser of advertising
I've ever seen.
I said, "Mike, I don't care
how many pillows you sell,
and now you're selling slippers
and sheets.
You're selling everything."
I said, "I don't care."
You can't afford
that much advertising.
I think --
You know what he does?
He waits till the show
is just ready to go on,
any empty slot, he says,
"I'll give you $200 for it,"
to Fox.
-Just what that crowd
was there for --
the details
of strategic ad buying.
[ Laughter ]
Man, I'd hate to be working
the ad sales phone
when Lindell calls mid-show.
"Hello?"
"This is Mike Lindell.
And it looks like Hannity
is about to go to commercial,
and I want the slot."
"We usually sell
those a few months out."
"Do you want
the 200 dollar bucks or not?"
Also, I love how blown away
Trump is that the guy
who sold pillows
branched out
to slippers and sheets.
It seems like it should be
a little more out there
to get that level
of amazement from Trump.
"He's not just
the pillow guy anymore.
He sells everything --
crossbows,
snake food,
X-rated snow globes.
You love those.
You're in for a treat when you
shake one of Mike's globes.
The snow moves around,
and what you see --
you can't believe what you see."
[ Laughter ]
Still, it's exciting that
Lindell is doing slippers now.
If they're as comfortable
as his pillows,
it probably sounds like this
when someone wearing them
walks through a room.
[ Clanging ]
[ Laughter ]
You know, you buy them
for spouses
you think are sneaking out
in the middle of the night
for affairs.
[ Clang ]
"Honey, are you
going somewhere?"
"Uh, just to the bathroom.
No-good stinking slippers."
"Honey, come back to bed."
"Okay."
[ Thud ]
"Whoa [bleep] pillow."
[ Laughter ]
I think that qualifies
as a play.
Think I just did a play.
[ Laughter ]
Can it get a Tony
if it's on TV first?
[ Laughter ]
Well, look into it.
It doesn't get any clearer
than this.
Trump is confessing
that he wanted
to overturn the 2020 election
and promising to pardon
the rioters if he wins in 2024.
It's openly a pro-coup movement.
They're publicly declaring
that they're going to try to do
the exact same thing next time.
The only way they could announce
their intentions
any more clearly is that they
started every sentence with...
-Hear ye, hear ye.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.